touche pas à mon pote
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
sera tous en régime font leur dire tiens
à donner à l écoute le truc qu'on avait
fait avant la fin de cette émission
batifole
[Applaudissements]
la vie
[Musique]
le coût de cet essor
votre canapé
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
pour tout le monde je dirige est
fracassée mal oh mon dieu
voter les mots
les milieux du csa ni comme moi que ce
soir je te dis je t'aime
joran pas l'antenne
[Applaudissements]
le bas
un jour l'un d'eux ne soit je ferai
elles sont belles
servette que le bac es
[Applaudissements]
et
chocolat
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
si la liste de tous les chroniqueurs
moi sans un regard
reine de saba
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
bien que le bois laqué jacking
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
c'est
moi je dirais qui tu viens avec moi tout
envahi
on a reçu vanille et c'est vrai qu'à un
moment aussi pourquoi reçoit pas
chocolat
[Applaudissements]
voilà